all right but first tonight's top story
special treatment for the entire Biden
Syndicate from your federal government
while we have big breaking news today it
turns out there are people who are above
the law in this country if you are a
Clinton if you are a Biden on the case
of Biden you can buy drugs you can smoke
crack you can hire a lot of prostitutes
skip out on paying your taxes or even
filing taxes you can dump a gun in a
trash can across from a high school not
register as federal laws require when
doing foreign business deals and sell
access to the White House through your
vice president Daddy and Biden's doj
will always have your back isn't that
great news too bad your last names are
not Biden now today two career IRS
officials bravely testified under oath
that the United States Department of
Justice shielded both Joe and Hunter
Biden for years no matter how egregious
their behavior now keep in mind these
two whistleblowers they're not political
actors is they are risking their careers
and their reputations and sacrificing
their right to privacy to expose what
they saw as malfeasance and outright
corruption they're coming forward
because it is the right thing to do and
they want the American people to know
the truth just listen to whistleblower
Democrat Joseph Ziegler in his own words
take a look
people are saying that I must be more
credible because I'm a Democrat who
happens to be married to a man I'm no
more credible than this man sitting next
to me
due to my actually due to my sexual
orientation or my political beliefs the
truth is my credibility comes today from
my job experience with the IRS and my
intimate knowledge of the agency's
standard and procedures I thought
Democrats loved whistleblowers they like
to hear say whistleblower if they can
impeach Donald Trump now this isn't some
kind of vast right-wing conspiracy
according to IRS agent Joseph Ziegler
there is a mountain of evidence that
Hunter Biden committed serious felonies
take a look
with respect to the 2014 tax year Hunter
Biden did not report any of the money he
earned from barisma for the 2014 tax
year which would have which would have
been a tax loss to the government of a
hundred and twenty four thousand dollars
thus as I read the Public Public
documents as the Department of Justice
action against Hunter Biden there is
nothing that indicates Hunter Biden will
be required to amend his false tax
return for 2018. a false tax return that
includes proper deductions improper
deductions for prostitutes sex clubs and
his child and his adult children's
tuition it appeared to me based on what
I experienced that the U.S attorney in
Delaware in our investigation was
constantly hamstrung limited and
marginalized by doj officials as well as
other U.S attorneys I still think that a
special counsel is necessary for this
investigation there's something to write
off prostitutes and sex club memberships
now despite everything you just heard
any investiga nation into the bidens was
apparently frowned upon at Biden's doj
and here's Ziegler on CBS listen to this
why did you want to interview Hunter
Biden's adult children so a lot of the
business deductions expenses related to
the adult children did you get the
approvals so we never received an
approvals to to talk to to to those
people what did the assistant U.S
attorney tell you that that's going to
get us into hot water is that in the IRS
handbook avoiding hot water no but I
mean I was asking to do these certain
things and roadblock after roadblock was
put up in front of me
protecting the Biden Syndicate remember
according to multiple Witnesses
investigators they were set to interview
Hunter Biden in 2020 as part of their
investigation but they were ultimately
blocked from doing so after FBI Federal
officials tipped the bidens off but even
without an interview it was a ton of
evidence of wrongdoing and that includes
bank records and suspicious activity
reports eyewitness accounts a ton of
material on zero experience Hunter
Biden's laptop viewer warning what
you're about to see is quite graphic the
children may want to run and get cookies
at this moment take a look
when Hunter Biden paid for this woman
to do this with him to travel across
state lines from California to
Washington D.C
on June 15th
this is a violation of the man act this
was prostitution this is an excerpt from
a SARS report that we've read in the
treasury and I think you all have looked
at these two showing that victim one was
supposedly an employee of a Wasco
um but but I would like to point out
this is not really what most paralegals
do
okay so why wasn't Hunter charged with
the felony after a five-year
investigation why just that slap on the
wrist uh is the doj is they really now
that politicized that corrupt that
abusively biased that weaponized for the
Democrats now according to the second
whistleblower IRS investigator Gary
shapley the Department of Justice has
well a lot of explaining to do take a
look
in November of 2022 the statute of
limitations was set to expire for the
2014 and 2015 Chargers in DC
which included the 2014 felonies for the
attempt to evade or defeat tax and fraud
or false statement regarding berezma
income earned by Hunter Biden in those
years the statute of limitations have
been extended through a tolling
agreement with Hunter buyers defense
counsel and they were willing to extend
it past November 2022
Weiss allowed those to expire I don't
claim to be privy to the United States
Attorney Weiss or attorney general
Garland's Communications but United
States Attorney Weiss told us that he
was not the deciding person that he had
requested and was denied special
Authority after D.C declined charges and
that if California declines you will
have to request special authorities
again I understood the gravity of those
admissions with their full
responsibility lies the United States
Attorney Weiss or attorney general
Garland is for congress the inspector
generals and ultimately the public to
decide all right let's not forget this
isn't about some kind of minor Financial
crime or tax mistake according to these
whistleblowers and the house oversight
chairman James Comer will join us in a
minute he this shows a pattern of what a
serious misconduct involving millions
and millions of dollars in foreign cash
with a paper trail a mile long watch
this
how much money did Hunter Biden and his
associates receive from the Romanian
company you identified
so that amount would be
uh from Romania so the approximate total
transfers from the Romania company would
have been 3.1 million to everyone 3.1
million how much did Hunter Biden is
business associates received from State
energy HK limited through the Robinson
Walker LLC so total transfers from State
energy HK to Rob Walker was three
million three million was there a
hundred thousand dollar payment from
cefc infrastructure to awasco PC Hunter
Biden's professional Corporation
uh yes chairman
approximately how much was transferred
to Hunter Biden and his business
associates through Hudson West 3.
so the total transfers from Hudson West
3 to everyone was 3.7 million 3.7
million how much money did Hunter Biden
and his business associates receive from
the Ukrainian company barisma
barisma paid to everyone involved 6.5
million 6.5 million barisma also paid
Blue Star Strategies and a law firm
hundreds of thousands of dollars
bringing the total barisma payments to
over 7 million dollars is that correct
that is correct 7.3 million 7.3 million
between 2014 and 2019 this brings the
total amount of foreign income streams
received to approximately 17 million
dollars correct that is correct
now ultimately we don't officially know
why foreign entities were paying the
bidens millions and millions of dollars
no one in the Biden family is willing or
able to answer that question uh in so
many cases we know they had no
experience at all in the Partnerships
that paid the millions and it certainly
wasn't Hunter's expertise in anything at
the time of these payments he was an
unreliable crackhead it also is unclear
why any other member of the Biden family
was receiving foreign cash through shell
corporations given their quote limited
abilities and between Joe Hunter the
weaponized doj the politicized FBI we
are now witnessing in this country the
single biggest abuse of power scandal in
modern American history and Corruption
and yet Congressional Democrats they
don't seem to care for them protecting
the big guy is way more important than
ever doing the right right thing they
lack the courage they have no more oral
compass from today's whistleblowers and
to think it wasn't that long ago when
Democrats revered whistleblowers even
hearsay whistleblowers well as it all
turns out it was all an act and now
we're suffering through one of the most
corrupt administrations in the history
of this country but I can tell you
tonight that the walls are beginning to
close in very tight on the entire Biden
family Syndicate we expect maybe Devin
Archer will be speaking next week hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else